here now with more reaction is
Lieutenant Colonel Oliver North Colonel
north president making very clear
tonight what this is about this is about
a precision strikes to send a message
and a deterrent to stop the use of
chemical weapons as the brutality in the
evil and to use the president's own
words here when we when he talked
frankly passionately tonight about all
this that it is barbarism and brutality
on display that we have been witnessed
with men women and children John last
night on your show I laid out target
list it looks like I guess right I
certainly didn't talk to anybody in the
administration but I said if there's
going to be an attack that's going to
determine use of chemical weapons by the
Syrian it had to be something more than
a one-off like glass tape and it clearly
looks like that's the case is going to
be in this it's gonna hit economic
target it's got to take out the
command-and-control nodes in Damascus
it's got a first take out as they did
the surface their missile defenses which
is what's the Russians put in and just
further to the comment that I just made
look when Ronald Reagan thirty two years
ago did the same thing the move are get
off when strikes out of Great Britain
and off to Navy carriers they didn't go
to Congress and beg for permission he
just did it and then what the Congress
said here's why I did it and I hope
that's what the President does tomorrow
after the dust suffers a little bit and
if necessary continues to strike at
those targets that are going to make
sure that this Assad regime cannot do
this again that means going after the
seaports that means going after
cratering all those runways and the
command and control and it I'll tell you
if the Russians persist in this effort
to deny us the use of our intelligence
surveillance assets meaning the
so-called drones and satellites we've
got the capacity in our military to shut
the communications down with the Assad
regime and the Russian and Iranian
patrons but they'll have to communicate
with Kerry effect if that's what they
want and I keep trying to interfere with
our Intelligence Surveillance
reconnaissance